[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
everybody
uh super excited today uh what date is
it
is it july 16th
it is july 16th it has been a year
in a lot of ways and um
i hope everybody's super well let's go
into the comments tyrone thomas good to
see you
mika coleman thank you for joining good
morning good morning good morning
ariana
enriquez good to see you thank you for
coming new will
jordan whittingham irena b travis sears
thank you gomi
in the building megan lennon in the
building
dustin how are you i missed all of you
good sorry are you okay over there
yeah hold on one second hold on one
second
um
well welcome to tea with garyvee
i am your host now
because gary just walks away sometimes
um so i see i'll just read comments now
i guess
i see a lot of links that was a terrible
i'm not job i'm not mentally prepared
oh you have to always be prepared bro
you're right you're right
someone asked if i had any new cards so
i got my own squirtle squad now
oh yeah you get serious about the
pokemon huh
yeah what are those psa nines tens i got
one nine and one
ten and a nine yellow cheeks
i like what i'm seeing i like what i'm
seeing
so everybody
all right let's get into the show that's
cool
crazy what's good bro dude what is up
how are you man long time no see
long time no see it's good to see you
how you been good man
besides uh everything being a little bit
weird and uh
you know just playing the adaptation
game
which is actually weirdly business as
usual it's a reason i've been able to
you know be in business for 15 years
plus for myself is because
you know you don't give up when crazy
stuff like this happens
no because the the punchline and for
everybody's watching is
if you give up that's actually the end
of the game like if you turn off your
nintendo it's over like if you keep
playing
contra and you can eventually win yeah
this is just like a momentary glitch
like a little bit of green
green screen on the nintendo just blow
in the cartridge you'll be good
look i think i think it comes down to a
lot of what i've been talking about for
the last three years which is like hey
this has been a long run of good stuff
and that's just not how the world
always works so save some money be smart
don't overextend yourself be thoughtful
you know be patient you know create
tried and true behaviors
be kind and you know i think um
i think uh i think this year has
challenged people in an incredible way
and
you know hopefully people are healthy
and and persevering
what can i answer for you um yeah i got
a couple questions for you if you don't
mind
um so the first thing that i want to
talk to you about
is really related to what we were just
talking about which is
the current market trends um you know
it's hard out here for
a lot of people but some people are
actually making a lot of money
right now consumer behavior has changed
a lot and in my
opinion as a big follower of you that is
your superpower
is consumer behavior you know you know
enough
about everything and you keep both of
your ears super glued to the street
and you hear you know from everybody and
so i feel like you know you just have
this unique you're uh you're an alien
bro
and you have the best insight on this
kind of stuff so
right now we are in a current bull
market you know stock market um
e-commerce sales are through the roof
you know
a lot of people are telling me i can't
make any money right now i'm like dude i
i i can't really help you if you can't
make money right now because
it's never been easier in your world of
reselling
yeah there's some people specifically
that are resellers that are like yo i'm
getting destroyed and you're like how is
that possible
when this is the greatest era of buying
on amazon
ever right and you know you're just not
adapting you know i've sold mostly books
for my entire career
but i can tell you i'm definitely not
selling books right now if you go to
google translate
is book sales down right now uh
i wouldn't say they're down i would say
they're up but a lot of things are up a
lot more
and those things have a much more profit
per unit
you know and then less labor involved
and stuff like that so
is the you know obviously when the when
the [ __ ] hit the fan
everybody was forced to shop online so
we have all these people that didn't
previously shop online they now shopped
online and they were like well this
shopping online shit's pretty nice you
know i like this
so now they're shopping online the
buying volume has increased
significantly i'd say
five to ten years of e-commerce consumer
behavior growth in you know the last
four months
so with that being said you know i've
been telling everybody like buckle down
you know this is gonna be the craziest
q4
ever in history like record level
sales for christmas and and leading up
to and i don't even think it's really
going to slow down from now until then i
almost feel sorry for people that are
just getting started now
because when it goes back to normal you
know they're going to have depression
because they're going to be right
they're going to be not as good yeah
you're like no no this is the normal we
were on a peak you know
but um you know we got what over a
million americans
on unemployment getting 600 a week
stimulus checks are coming in
you know tens of millions of americans
are unemployed in general
and you even hear people you know you
post how good your sales are and people
are like oh it's those stimulus checks
you know even
even in the reselling community you know
not so out in the open but
people are like bring on wave two bring
on wave three like you know we were
making a lot of money
two and three of stimulus checks no of
locked
yeah i mean it's it's dark but you know
people are making money i don't think
people really
want people to get sick or whatever but
people have never made money real easily
so in your opinion um i think it's about
like 11 days 10 days out until they
decide to maybe stop the 600
a week unemployment checks do you see
this trend continuing through
the holiday season and onward or do you
see
like a depression era level
you know i don't think it's a depression
level but i do think
that within a 10-year window
we need to really pay the piper and
we're just printing money
and people are getting checks to take
care of themselves
that are out of jobs and they're going
out and buying cds
not really i just like that they're just
buying things
this is a very consumer world people
don't like saving
um and so the
fundamentals are not exciting you know
the timing of when
i have no idea but um there is there's
definitely
incredible short-term behavior which
leads to
a lot of vulnerabilities i'm with you i
think you know i don't think anyone's
going outside
for real until after this year so
i think q4
the shopping behavior is so intense
they're not going to go to physical
stores all that goes online so they'll
be incredible
opportunity through the end of the if
i'm in your business i go hammy ham ham
to the end of the year and i literally
take 50 percent of the money i make and
put it in the bank and let it sit there
as cash yep safety net
that's literally what i would do i would
if i made 200 000
in sales i would take 100 put in the
bank and with that 100 i would continue
to buy things run my business blah blah
blah
that's what i would do yeah there's a
million factors the election's a huge
factor
um you know there's just you know every
day
anything could happen i mean there could
be a new pandemic i mean you know
so you know i i think saving money
needs to be thought through but like
navigating through good or bad times
just takes execution and mentality like
whether it comes or goes or disappears
or doesn't disappear
it's kind of irrelevant that is
completely out of our control i'm
i am quick to react to what's happening
but i can't predict
i don't predict i don't know i don't see
future i definitely know that
when the government disproportionately
gives out gazillions of dollars
and then the humans in society instead
of saving it or
doing smart things with it go and buy
materialistic things
and then when we get out of it people
can't get jobs and those checks are not
going to be there
that's a problem yep makes a lot of
sense to me
so so uh the next question
that i got for you is uh basically a
round
it's a really selfish question so but um
basically around how you
built up team gary vee i'm looking to do
the same thing for myself
you know sometime within the last year
or two i realized you know i can't
do everything i can't i can't even post
instagram every single day if i have to
also
check all my dms and check email it's
madness i'm losing money you know
opportunities i'm
i'm missing opportunities you know um so
the first hire for me was a a really
badass personal assistant shout out
mandy
hey mandy she makes everything happen
for me
um i have a full-time video editor um
and i have an intern and that's pretty
much the entire team right now
and i'm curious with you how was the
beginning of team garyvee who was the
first hires what are the most important
pieces of the puzzle
maybe what mistakes have you made admin
admin admins the most important piece so
i'm glad you went down that route the
next
most important piece is the right hand
coordinator of the content the andy k
and then next to most important piece is
the creatives
in my world that was steve unwin back in
the askgaryvee days
zach moy who runs sasha the sasha group
one of the vrx companies creative
department now
um so for me it's designer video person
and writer
are the three essential pieces someone
who writes copy
somebody who makes pictures
and somebody who makes video assets a
coordinator so that's the four-person
team because we need the project manager
the architect the gm the person that's
your
right full-time full-time like photo
maker for content full-time copywriter
yep assistant full-time video assistant
who makes sure all the content is coming
out which probably includes scheduling
five person team assistant the
coordinator project manager
gm whatever you want to call her him
right
design image video design
and then copywriting and you hire them
as you can afford them
you know i didn't hire all five at first
either what are the most important out
of them
out of the after the assistant assistant
i would probably then go to editor i
would go assistant
i would probably go coordinator that can
also do
either video or creative at first so
like an organized video or
design maker um then i would bring in
a design maker or video person depending
on where you want to go
you would then have to be the generator
of ideas
or the coordinator or the admin would
have to
um then then the coordinator who also
has to really give the ideas
and and help then the writer and then
either the video or design person
depending on which one you didn't
do prior awesome that's cool man i
appreciate it i know uh
you you still do a lot of the creative
stuff yourself and you get your eyes i
still write up i still
write all the copy and like you know
ideate with the team my meeting right
after this is ideation with the team so
content man content's the [ __ ]
gateway awesome real quick before
we take off i want to um hit you with a
little
piece i don't remember i don't know if
you remember this but when i first
started building my personal brand and
i'm following you i'm on everything you
do i'm watching it
i was really cynical back then this was
you know almost five years ago and i
remember
you know i was listening to everything
you say you know [ __ ] automation be real
you know
and you had posted something and i
forget the exact situation on twitter
but it was extremely fast like
humanly fast you know reactiveness on
your part
and then i replied yeah like to
something i don't remember but
i was like i commented something along
the lines of you know like
says the guy that doesn't use automation
you know
like calling you out using automation
and i swear to god 10 seconds later you
replied with the video that said
these two thumbs [ __ ] these two
thumb
and then i was like holy [ __ ] like he
like came at me
like people don't do that you know and
then uh
i said something like my bad you know
and you just replied the simplest thing
three words and it changed my life
really because i was real cynical you
just said
cynics never win can you explain that
for the audience what you mean by that
first of all it's an epic story um and i
i've done that's happened more than once
i'm trying to remember if i remember the
exact one
but uh deciding to look at the world
first of all cynics never win is
something that really
sits with me because there's a lot of
people who are cynical
who are hurting or are concerned or
coming from a place of fear
and i have a lot of empathy for it but
what it means is
you're looking for
bad you're looking for the wrong you're
spending energy
and often time looking for the i got you
or like oh these people like that person
let me prove that that person's not as
good as that like there's a
underlining i don't like the word
jealousy believe it or not
i i don't know why i don't like that
word but i don't really
if you search the garyvee rarely yeah
you know
it's not about that it's not about me
wanting to be jealous i don't even like
to label people jealous
because i think that that's an not a
nice way to say something
to somebody who actually is probably
hurting
slash admiring someone so like it's a i
don't know but nonetheless
spending energy looking for bad
is just a bad use of time you know
to me it's like ins like all that time
and energy
spent creeping waiting for the aha
could all be put towards positive
behavior and doing something for
yourself
and bringing value it's just literally
seeing the
world in a negative light instead of a
positive light
it comes down to confidence and kind of
being in your own bubble for me
i i love i always lead with
love and belief and and trust is given
and then if one proves that that wasn't
a good idea
then i'm okay with that but that doesn't
hurt my confidence
right it doesn't upset me i don't feel
like they let me down
so many people are guarded and and i
think that that
is something i just think a lot about
it's just it's exhausting
to be around cynics um people that are
looking for
the wrong and right now i think the
reason so many people are anxious and
tired
is our entire culture our entire country
in a lot of ways is on tilt and cynical
and just like every day looking for
the wrong and that's that's daunting and
i think it's leading to a lot of um
a lot of pain which makes me unhappy
for so many people which is why i
observe it i watch it but it's also that
why i spend my time doing actions like
this
because i want to bring you know i'm
hoping this hour brings a lot of
positivity and a lot of value to people
oh yeah you know you're always bringing
the value man um
that man that uh the way you replied to
me is exactly
what i needed you know to understand
that uh
if you if you're cynical you know i i
felt so bad in that moment when i called
you out and you were like no i did it
that's me
for real you were wrong and that's when
i realized i'd rather be naive
and wrong you know than than cynical
because if i'm right then i assume you
did it and later i found out you were
using automation
i don't feel bad you know i don't look
like yeah it's like it's like it's like
that's bad on them that's my point which
is like bad will always lose in the end
good will always win the end the end the
end the end and it's like
who are all we it almost takes like to
me the reason i don't search out is i
don't have enough
ego to think like it's my job to figure
it out like the world will take care of
you
you may be winning for a little while
with your trickery but that [ __ ] will
always lose in the end so i don't even
need to spend my energy on that because
the negative thing will lose in the end
yep
even though it might look like they're
not people like oh yeah but did you see
his mercedes i'm like you don't
understand what's happening in that
man's soul
you don't know how that man goes to
sleep with pills and alcohol don't think
he's winning because he's got some money
the [ __ ] the matter with you yep
awesome
love you gary thank you for your time
brother peace let's move
all right let's wrap it up let's let's
speed this up a little bit
what's up what's good now how are you we
preaching positivity
first off we actually ran out of tea
bags but being irish it's five o'clock
summer so we uh
have a little
little back story this is uh now my
brother i'm killian
32 year old 26 year old been traveling
around the world but
i just wanted to go back a little bit
further i didn't have the best start to
life
i was born with like a pretty rare
heart condition called troglous or tear
i undergone my first operation whenever
it was four weeks old
came through it by all the doctors
disbelief and then had he was through
another one
again and then they said i would
probably need another operation it was
16 and now 32 as i said
and i haven't needed one since
thankfully that's kind of inspired me
just watching your stuff as well has
really
pushed me to travel around the world
just you always preach about one life
one opportunity just get out there and
do [ __ ] and that's what i've been doing
trying to pursue our career dream to
make in the music industry
without water now pretty much like
videographer
singer songwriter so like it kind of
works out like the billy eilish
and the phineas kind of like little
synergy i love that i love that
uh so pretty much just a bit of context
about me um i'm niall
26 years old started saying like 10
years ago
um actually funny story i was like on
the xbox you know in the little like
headset like singing
with my friends on live like xbox 360.
like a skill competition won it and kind
of snowballed from there
and then got the opportunity to travel
for a few years then
so pretty much i stayed afloat like
hustled and
busted and stuff you know just to keep
my living
and then after that came home did the x
factor uk
back in 2016 which is pretty amazing
not pretty far from that so from that
i've like been building connections and
like you know
hustling from there and i moved to
toronto two years ago because my
brothers moved here
four years ago i think yeah but four
years ago there's two other brothers so
there's four of us so
at the moment
the only thing i'm thinking right now is
i'm trying to really listen because the
only thing that just went through my
brain was like i need to hang out with
these four [ __ ] brothers
keep it going keep going so pretty much
um since i've been in toronto
uh i started i mean like i've been
singing for 10 years but i didn't really
take it seriously as i got a career
until about four years ago since the
xbox kind of inspired me and
made me realize that i can really you
know make this this
career and obviously kellyanne is a
videographer content creator so
it goes really hard so right now
i've been really focusing on like you
know honing in on my original music and
making sure that
i come across as authentic as like
um an artist should but my first
question was it's weird sex i never
thought i'd be this person but
like since quarantine i've been feeling
my like mental health issues like a lot
of weird anxiety but like
a lot a lot of things like um feel like
you're running out of time in your
moment like
that was like yeah that was one of the
points so
pretty much bro now i really like it
notice how i zoned in right on that it's
super cool makes sense right like you
made this move you've got this momentum
going
[ __ ] as soon as i [ __ ] finally figure
out what i want to do and i've got some
momentum going
[ __ ] kovic like you know like that
you know people always
people go to that place the reality is
it's just not true what could happen is
you'll never have a time
where you have this much downtime with
you and your brother just right here
instead of being like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
me up you need to go on the offense
see the posit it's back to the last
thing it's either cynicism or optimism
like you and your bro are like [ __ ]
chilling together and like just [ __ ]
make
he makes videos you sing just [ __ ]
make yeah
have been going through your faces i'm
like real like let's go hard for a month
and then all of a sudden
obviously you know yourself working with
your brother and your dad like growing
up
it sometimes it gets a bit like flashing
of heads and we both want the same dream
and the goal at the end of the the
tunnel
but uh sometimes you just clash heads
and like are we're very stubborn people
that's kind of like an irish mentality
we stubborn
and so obviously we're both fighting the
same thing
this is where i use darkness for light
you know every time i'm struggling
and i've said this for anybody who
follows me i go into a very dark place
of like
and you know yeah we just lost all that
business or this bad thing happened
but somebody could call me right now and
say my mom died right so like
not from my standpoint like like anytime
you're pissed at your brother
if he was my brother it'd be so easy i'd
be like damn he shouldn't even be alive
his heart's [ __ ] up like like like
honestly i would like literally go there
every time and i think it defuses
the you know like you guys are fighting
about should we make a video or how
should a [ __ ] video be made
and i'd be like damn i'm just happy my
brother's alive
i mean i mean i really go to that place
me and my dad had a lot of friction
a lot you know me and my dad's the world
totally different you know i came in hot
and every time it got real bad like
i would cry when we would fight in my
20s you know but i would go
back to my office and be like you know
cool but like
thank god he's alive he lost his dad at
15. you know what i mean
yeah like it's perspective like like
it's
just momentum of how you see the world
i see the world like you're lucky as
[ __ ] that you're
alive during an internet era during
covid because if your parents
lived through covet there was no
internet there was no connection there
was no this
is a [ __ ] miracle out here yeah true
so like a follow-up question that was
because of like
feeling like a bit anxious and you know
things like that
my motivation comes in waves so like for
a month
like on it like real good and then like
two weeks off then
two weeks old good sounds great
better than zero motivation bro people
judge themselves
nobody goes 365 dude i'm buying sports
cards and spending time on ebay all day
long the last month
because i needed clearly subconsciously
i needed the release
yeah i'm not beating up myself that i'm
not prepping for huge meetings
where millions of dollars on the line
because i'm looking up dr j rookies
at you know midnight don't judge
yourself
and by the way you're right you're right
now do you write
yeah of course yeah i've been running
for the last like two three years pretty
much
a bit more like authentic at writing is
that like i i'm 26 at like 23 i came out
so like that was a huge burden off my
shoulders
so from that i think i kind of released
something in me where i could fight more
authentically and like
you were hiding you were hiding before
yeah pretty much yeah
so yeah which is which is amazing
congratulations so like my big thing is
take this time together and when you get
into the zone of going
dark or not motivated see if you can
make i mean you may find out that's when
you write your most authentic [ __ ]
oh 100 percent like it's the proofs in
the pudding like a definitely
honestly i think you're judging yourself
i would argue that the number one thing
that [ __ ] up the 10
000 people that are watching this right
now every single day is their
disproportionate judgment of their own
selves
yeah yeah you're just living out here
bro you're just trying
like me like you bro like every [ __ ]
person like digging a brave like you
know
like in the comments like captain like
stop
like everyone's just beating themselves
up for no reason like i listen
if you can't be your number one fan who
the [ __ ] gonna be it um and i think it
comes with
humility and also understanding like
comparison destroys people like i don't
give a [ __ ] about billy eilish and her
[ __ ] brother
yeah like a great motivation they're
[ __ ] amazing sure
but [ __ ] that like don't compare and
love yourself
don't compare and love yourself don't
compare and love yourself don't compare
and love yourself
you [ __ ] drill into your [ __ ] dome
and your whole life
got a little headed get a little you
know
i think you're right like that's every
little problem that like small things
that build up that make you feel a
certain way is
like self-esteem and self-love and like
every time i get into like a
disappointed with myself which is the
worst right i'm just like
like right before i go it's like it's
almost like right before i cross over
into a place i've really not been which
is like
real negative space i'm just like
you know what everybody else sucks too
i mean i mean yeah i mean
but they can't turn it back on to like a
lighter note as well it's obviously not
always dark here like we always
for sure i'm sure you're
the key here and why this is probably
resonating for a lot of people
is if you're 88 fun but 12 percent
actual anxiety and depression and
awkwardness and dark
that 12 is heavier than the 88 yeah of
course
good i was just gonna say like six out
of seven days a week i'm like
fine and all just kind of like pay bills
and stuff um
i'm still trying to find ways to like
make money um
off like social media and music and
stuff i only have one single out of the
minute but i've got a lot of like back
burning
uh it was like loads of songs yeah we've
been making like over the last couple of
years like a lot of trips back and forth
in new york and land and making
connections like some great connections
like uh black eyed peas manager we were
in the studio with him showing his work
off so like
i i like to think myself as a very good
like connector between people i'm good
at hustling that's why i managed to get
the intro for you guys
lacking attention yeah pretty much it i
hit up dustin and zee and just
befriended them and obviously provided
value and then made that video
i seen that yesterday this man did this
man charm you
yeah i mean they just made it i'm
calling you there
all right get out of here no come on
come back
so we're just just building connections
and uh just seeing just
taking what one day is the timing to see
how things go and obviously with your
help
and obviously i know you have a lot of
times with your your music right now man
mike boyd that's something i love that
maybe it's further down the line so
might
make it 100 dustin put him in boyd
together let's get let's get
now song on the playlist let's get them
huge exposure okay yeah thanks man
it's done it's done listen to me on the
seventh day of week
when you go to that place turn it into
enjoyment
not anxiety meaning when you don't feel
it then you don't feel it
yeah i'm telling you enjoy
and put put the down day on a pedestal
of like my body's telling me i need to
rest
and that's it play video games watch a
movie
talk to your like convert that beginning
you know it's kind of like my back's all
[ __ ] up from growing up in the liquor
store and i've worked on the last five
years with soft tissue so i talk about
it a lot
but last couple weeks because i've been
really going hand i'm starting to really
get like some things going here like
something's clearly happened where i'm
getting i'm starting to spasm a little
bit in my back again and even though i'm
rolling heavily and i just haven't
completely figured it out but it's funny
i equate it to this sometimes i can feel
my
muscles about to lock and and sometimes
i can turn
the right way and it just stops it at
other times
it just i can't get it and it just goes
into lock mode
it's kind of how i think about the
mentality of this you know like when you
feel it brewing
convert it into perspective of like
gratitude of being alive
and lack of judgment on yourself and
just [ __ ] enjoy the day
and watch your favorite movie ten times
over play video games
or or call your most positive friends if
you're fighting with bro at that moment
call positive friends if you're awesome
with bro at that moment
just be thankful for this time be like
bro let's just do some different [ __ ]
let's
get into like a netflix show or let's
[ __ ] play video games like just don't
beat yourself
up bro this is like because at the end
of the day like you said it's about like
loving what you do and like
country obviously like i really want to
be successful and like
period period stop right there stop
right there
i i would argue it would be very hard
for anybody to be
more ambitious than me i'm in the top
tier i feel like other people are the
same like nobody was hungrier
i'm still you can't imagine i think i'm
dirt right now i know everything that's
going on with me and i'm in full dirt
mode
garbage nothing like haven't even
started like chip on shoulder like you
can't if you
actually read the thoughts in my mind
you'd be like what the [ __ ] the matter
with this dude
i haven't [ __ ] even like like my
hunger i'm [ __ ]
starving out here however ambition
should be separate from self-love just
you know what
unfortunately people's ambition tears
them down
often
for sure you understand your ambitions
leading to anxiety you're like
this is why covert [ __ ] you up you're
like [ __ ] we had our [ __ ] going to fly
to l.a
no no take that and be like no we can
just make content
you're so lucky to have each other how
many people are sitting by themselves
right now
you got your [ __ ] bros you're [ __ ]
together [ __ ] make
exactly yeah whatever the [ __ ] sign
is behind you in the window sell that
[ __ ]
and like like [ __ ] just go like just
like i'm telling you man just go on the
offense
it's my friend's mirror but i i i'm not
telling her
i gotta run love you boys one last
[ __ ]
30 seconds just kill myself i didn't
basically uh next time we're back and
forward to l.a i'd love to get a chance
to get like a real
cup of tea or beer with you and they
have a little 10 minutes even
get to new york you got 10 minutes it's
done
[Music]
jason yo gary v
what's good bro this is wild man
where are you from uh i'm out of north
carolina
um yeah raleigh uh i know you're trying
to go kind of quick right now so
um i just wanted to say i hope you're
doing well i hope the family's good
i know that's your night and um there
was like there was a little gap where
there weren't any videos coming out and
i was like oh man i hope
everybody's good um but yeah like
basically um let me tell you a little
bit about
about me and my story so uh three years
ago i started a company
in my um uncle's business in the
warehouse
in a closet i didn't even have lighting
i'm stealing wi-fi and printer paper
and like um you know it's just me
working 14 hours a day um
cut to our first full year 2019
um we're we're in the black we did 1.2
million in revenue
um just like uh basically the business
model
is um i sell obsolete
electronic parts to some of the biggest
like uh you know northrop grumman
raytheon boeing
even nasa i've actually even sold some
equipment to your boy over
at facebook before uh i love it yeah
it's cool
it's really cool so it's you know and
what i've been thinking lately is like
um this is selling a part right this is
selling a physical piece
of equipment and and and i'm
trying to you know i love it i love the
business i love being an entrepreneur i
want to go to the next thing i want to
do something
that's like selling ip selling strategy
um you know and i'm just really curious
like
how did you go from running the wine
business
um and selling a physical product to
like
okay now i can do the next thing like
i'm making content ahead of me doing it
by sitting down you know i don't know if
you've seen the videos clips of like
you know from like 10 years ago where i
was a little chubbier and like shaved my
head and was making videos during that
era
um i just started making content and at
first people were like [ __ ] you why boy
stay in your lane you don't know
business and i'm like what you know like
the feedback was actually quite negative
when i started making content around
business
because i was in the wine business i was
in the wine store i was a wine guy
but i just kept making it because i knew
what i was talking about
and eventually i found my audience and
my audience found me
and i just made content on twitter on
ustream on
viddler on myspace
on facebook on social cam and bert and
and
clark like the all these little startups
at the time
you know that uh orchid and high five
and
you know tag world all these things are
long forgotten but i [ __ ]
i made i made a made a mate so it's
interesting you say that
one second excuse me for one second
dustin
prep can you prep this episode to end
with the announcement of vayner gaming
because i see my twitch family here okay
uh maybe the post from instagram that i
put up yesterday maybe that can
you can do that okay thank you vayner
gaming
go ahead yeah um it's actually
funny you mentioned that because i've
started to mess a lot um play with music
djing and mixing and i keep going back
and forth between like
should i just record every hour long set
or mix
and post all of it
yes or or should i like get the
jason i know what i'm talking about yeah
you do i know that
the strengths the good [ __ ] you do in
there is gonna help you
the flaws the [ __ ] you don't know is
gonna help you
word got it got it man i love the
process people like the journey
yeah that's the rocky the rocky movies
are better in him prepping for the fight
than even the [ __ ] fight
yeah like it's the imperfection that
makes it interesting a hundred percent
everybody out here just like i saw
somebody who's like yo why is carrie
being on me
why is gary vee's t for garyvee
equipment not up to par like people are
complaining about the sound right now
like [ __ ] that man it's the [ __ ]
imperfections like cool
go watch some other show that's got
[ __ ] the best production in the world
i got [ __ ] dustin and we just [ __ ]
sit here press the button
we joke we put out great [ __ ] fire
and we do what we [ __ ] can
the end i got [ __ ] backlighting i
don't give a [ __ ] it's the [ __ ]
content it's the process
the imperfections are the [ __ ] beauty
got it
word um thank you so much man wow that's
all i wanted
yes yeah i want to say um i have
something for you
uh for it that's around hustling sports
cards
and um i think it's going to be
extremely helpful
and uh if you could follow me on
instagram i'll message it to you
um you're gonna love love it and uh
and i find everything i like the hustle
because you know what's cool
you can just dm it to me without me
following you on the gram
but i really want to give you that
follow so there you go
all right thank you gary yo i appreciate
everything you do man thank you i
appreciate more we'll talk soon let's
keep moving
dustin is awesome that's the point like
dustin get in here
this guy this guy this guy's better than
good lighting and good audio
people complaining about the audio fix
it doesn't let's keep moving
we can't but anyway is it because of my
headphones dust instead of like plugged
in
um i mean i i think it sounds fine but
yeah i think
that i mean having these would be better
yeah i lost them but i'll find more it's
all good
see you
oh my god oh my hi gary hi how do you
pronounce your name
diana diana so pretty yeah thanks
uh i am extremely nervous
so i i need to apologize if you hear
some weird noises in the background
it's because i love your family i love
you don't worry about that
tell your family to get loud go ahead so
um i relate a little bit of a quick
backstory before i asked my question
and it relates a lot with the person you
just finished talking to
because it relates to being the
imperfection
and putting yourself out there so
i am an artist i'm a graphic designer
full-time
and i create illustrations and like
my little like little pins like these
and i like
try to sell them so
i graduated with an art degree and i got
myself in a lot of debt
like a lot like over a hundred thousand
dollars and
i didn't like get on it right away
because
uh i was scared of dealing with money my
family
is also an immigrant family we're from
cuba i came when i was nine
so we like worked really hard and money
came always really hard and you had to
like
kind of hoard it and not do it like
spend it right
so um i was always scared of handling
money so i didn't tackle that loan like
right away
so as i got older i
you know i went off to california and
like wanted to do my own thing
but then they realized about two years
in that i needed to come back because
san francisco was way too expensive and
i needed to do something else i moved
back with my family and this is like my
room
and this is where like my whole life is
at pretty much
like this is all my stuff like i don't
have anything else anywhere else
so my question to you is i
i need to buckle down um for the next
year to two years while i'm here
and like produce art so that i can i
have a full-time job
that i'm making enough money that i can
kind of pay my
my bills and then put it into loan but i
am
trying to produce more art so that i can
sell it and i can
get a little bit extra to put into those
phones so i can like
close them out okay the biggest thing is
um i actually wrote down my question
before i forgot
it's how do you distance yourself from
your art
enough so that it doesn't feel like you
are putting a piece of yourself
out there and then feel the rejection
when it's
not um being like people are not liking
it or commenting it or buying it
um but you don't want to take it as a
reflection of who
like yourself worth because i've i've
dealt
with a lot of uh so your account your
account's awesome
thank you i keep losing
whenever i try to be myself on there
yo what's up with this [ __ ] that you
don't follow me
i follow you on tick-tock i love your
tic-tac stuff
i will follow you on there too i promise
i follow you on zigzag on twitter
and youtube and everywhere else i'm
kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding
i follow you all right everybody should
follow you because i really you know
what's funny your drawing style is
very in my zone like i like this kind of
characters and stuff
it's really good thank you like really
good actually
yeah i love creating characters so like
i'll take a person and
characterize it um would you i'd love
for you to do some stuff for my account
and we'll we'll tag you and give you
some
we you should talk to andy i'd love to
work with you definitely i would love
that
that would be really fun uh a couple
things one
uh i actually don't think you should
detach i think you should understand
that you're making the art that you want
to make and sometimes commercially it'll
be successful and sometimes you don't
i put out enormous amount of things that
people don't like in any shape or form
or give a [ __ ] about
and i find that exciting not devastating
i don't take it personal because i'm not
in control of people's opinions i'm in
control of what i get to
make because i want to make it and
sometimes that's going to be
commercially successful
and sometimes it's not but i didn't make
it to be commercially successful
i made it because i wanted to make it
you need to make it about your process
not the validation of people
appreciating it
yeah so i i kind of started on tech talk
because i had started before and i kind
of like got off of it because i wasn't
getting a lot of views and stuff and
then like i started listening to you and
i'm like i need to get on that like
yesterday so i started on it and i'm
posting about one to two a day
and i always feel really like i don't
have enough stuff to post because like
creating pins like these like take a
long time
and then uh creating my illustration
sometimes takes a long time trying to
balance my full-time job with
illustrating
so um it's it's kind of like i don't
know
you do you do know that you're you're
one
illustration away from your career
changing right
yeah i i know that but it doesn't feel
that way to me
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah it feels to you
i need you to know it's true
yeah like look here you're in the cliche
spot that a lot of people that are
watching are in which is
you're now going through this whole
process of like [ __ ] i got into this
debt
i'm back home you go you know it just
makes sense
the reality is the part that you don't
know is how young you are
yeah it doesn't feel that way because
it's so it goes back to
being with family right so
yeah i get it russian families chinese
families black families like
you know i get it i get it so to them i
am 30 years old
don't have a significant other don't
have kids don't have my life
together so i i hear that all the time
so trying to shut that off
and focus it's hard it's been hard it's
hard
which is why these things are so
important
you need to shut them out you need to be
grateful for them
you can't resent them at least they're
giving you a shelter right now you don't
have cost of
home right you need to be thankful for
what they give you and you need to be
empathetic and understanding why they're
stressed
your parents your grandparents or
whoever's around they grew up in a
different era
where 30 year old women already have
three [ __ ] children in the old land
right like
you're you're a woman of a new
generation the end there's nothing else
to say
like i understand where i have a lot of
empathy for where they come from
that is how they view the world i knew
the world
in that at 34 years old i started over i
spent 12 years of my career building a
big business for my dad
but i built it for my dad i was in a
family business i didn't get paid a lot
of money because it was the family
business
and i built it for my dad and i left at
34 and i had no self
i had no financial worth i was like had
to start over
so for me you can imagine when i hear 30
and two more years i'm like oh you're a
baby
and then when i look and actually see
that you're talented i'm like oh [ __ ]
now all i have to do is get her to
believe that she just needs to put out
as much as she possibly can
because it's gonna be one single piece
of content that's gonna change her world
yeah i mean it's one moment look what
just happened here you got on this show
and [ __ ] already i'm like interested
in working with you and i have a huge
platform it's because you're great not
because i mean there's plenty of people
that have been on the show that i don't
want to work with
it's because i think you're really
really good i'm sure you picked up a ton
of followers just right now as well
because let's see
you've picked up like 300 followers
already listen everybody who's here
please follow right here and dmr
i think i think some of you should make
logos with her and
pins and like i'd love for you to make
me a design and we'll make
a thousand pins and then maybe i'll give
it away to people on my text messaging
platform or something so
oh yeah that will be awesome yeah
you've got these earbuds where you just
play music and people that inspire you
all positivity all positivity practical
positivity not delusion
or move out and you move in with friends
so you don't have to hear it those are
your two
options and then you just stay the
course yeah that's
i'm gonna have to block it off because
right now i need to focus on on
on those loans and i mean the time that
i've been here already i've been able to
like close down three loans like cash
like here
take it like so i still have like two
more that i need to like
like focus on right and um it's it's
that it's that self-worth that i keep
attaching
my self-worth to to my work so when you
talk about insecurity and
putting yourself out there and posting
and keep posting no matter what
that's where where it comes for me it's
it's that self-worth i'm attaching it to
what i'm putting out there and
you that's insecurity and ego
yeah look you're not confused that
you're good
you're too good to not think you're good
you know what i mean no matter how
insecure or beat up you are deep down
you know you're good
so that it's a mix of insecurity and ego
because you know you're good
yeah you need to understand that i think
i'm the best
i literally think i'm the best literally
i believe i am the best in the world at
what i do
yet every day i put out stuff that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about
it's liberating yeah
so just but how do you
let's try this diana let's start with
this what you're doing now
isn't working for you enough yeah you're
not happy enough
so more tuning your parents out more
putting out content and getting used to
it not doing well
yeah and that's why i tried to tic tac
because i wanted i wanted to push myself
to
do something out of my comfort zone and
that but
you also started doing tik tok because
you believed in me and
it was a new safe place i need you to
get comfortable with
negativity and push back not escape to
tick tock
to be free yeah yeah yeah tick-tock was
an outlet for a lot of people that got
too fancy on instagram that's why i work
for people like oh this is easy and fun
but nobody gives a [ __ ]
until that becomes the platform and then
the same thing comes over we need to fix
the well not the set
sync that was a tactic for you to escape
a place where judgment was thriving
and insecurity was thriving you
understand i
it's like it's like training for a fight
i don't know if you follow boxing or mma
but like when you see these people get
punched in the [ __ ] face
or in this ribs and you're like or like
i was watching the fight the other day
and guys
slamming on the guy's [ __ ] toes and
me and my brother and brother-in-law are
just like laughing be like one toe stomp
would crush us
that's because we haven't trained for
getting [ __ ] stepped on the toe
like with [ __ ] all the other person's
might however
if i started training right now for
getting stepped on my toes by another
man with all his might
in two years i'd be able to handle it
that's what i need you to do as an
artist
i need you to put out something every
day and get comfortable
with losing people are uncomfortable
with losing
when you have as much natural talent as
you do you probably got good accolades
and positive reinforcement
for it it became your positive place
it's the place where you got positive
reinforcement
in your teenage and early years it
became your safe place but now that
you're putting it to the market your
market's not your teachers and your
parents and your friends
they're gonna tell you go [ __ ] yourself
at times you need to get comfortable
with that yeah the game of life
is getting to fall in love with losing
and negativity
not with positivity
the game of life is predicated on
getting comfortable and enjoy
i [ __ ] enjoy it dana i enjoy when
they don't like it
i enjoy when they tell me i can't
you need to to practice you need to
practice
yeah the only way to practice is to put
it out there 100
yeah it's just opinions
you also have to know that when you put
out something that goes viral or [ __ ]
bananas you also can't get too high on
that
you can't let the work be the validation
you need the process of doing it to be
the validation
you have to figure that out
yeah that's that's true like i wanna i
wanna be able to focus on the process
and share that
as much as i want to share the final
product so do that
but some yeah but
no so for me i um
i since my drawings don't turn out
perfect like from the very beginning
it's a process right so you're perfect
where is this perfect like besides kurt
henning there is no mr perfect there is
no mrs perfect like
who who is this perfect person that's
you talking to yourself about [ __ ]
perfect
[ __ ] perfect i don't wanna like i don't
even say that word unless i need to
address somebody who's [ __ ] fall in
love it
with that [ __ ] word that [ __ ]
words a piece of [ __ ] perfect
is a [ __ ] word used to make yourself
upset
yeah [ __ ] that word and i use it as
procrastination as well
like i end up not doing it because i
want it perfect
perfect is a veil for not doing
yeah that's so true
okay i i'm like
my heart is like beating so fast because
i
i honestly think that this was put in
front of me to talk to you today like as
a sign
because i honestly just started
following you like a few weeks ago and
i've been
listening to your stuff like back and
forth while i work
so many people there's so many people
there's like thousands of thousand
people here
who've been watching for seven years
have been dying to get on this show
and you're out here like yo i i i met
you yesterday here i am i love it i
don't know
i i texted you i texted your number
yesterday and i was like
i don't know if this is gonna go through
or not but like i still asked my
question and then saying replied and i
was like holy [ __ ]
like what is going on this is like a
sign from the universe and i could not
be more thankful
for the opportunity to chat with you and
and
i'm going to rewatch this clip like
every day
exactly when you walk into your home
when you leave leave your home
you put in those earpods and you listen
to this literally
literally literally and that's escaping
like tick-tock at some point you sit
down with your parents and say i am so
thankful
that i have parents that love me so much
and don't think i have my life together
and i understand you and the way you
grew up but i promise you i do
and i have so much more time to make it
perfect for me
and i hope you enjoy the way i decide to
live my life
yeah and i understand immigrant parents
you're not talking to somebody who
doesn't understand
yeah they understand they want you to
follow like a straight line of what life
is they want you to live the life
that they want you to live the problem
is that's not in your best interest
yeah it's not and i'm i'm not i'm not
that way i
i don't think that way either and it's
that's what causes the tension between
us and the fights and the
you know you you need to you need to
become more selfless when you talk to
your parents
yeah instead of worrying about defending
yourself you need to actually reverse it
you need to flip it on them and say
i love you so much for caring about me
so much
you gotta flip it on you gotta eat you
gotta eminem them you know like
eminem in eight mile when he like disses
himself and then the other guy
what the [ __ ] you need to basically do
that same thing with your parents i love
you thank you thank you and then after a
while you do that great transition
that he does to clarence you say mom i
love you mom i love you mom i love you
and then you say you know mom i do know
something about you
i know that you resent dad for this and
i know that you're mad that you started
having kids this early and i know that
you're pissed that you never got to
follow your dream
when you flip that [ __ ] on parents i
love you i love you i love you instead
of [ __ ] you this is my life you don't
know
instead of that i love you i love you i
love you thank you for caring about me
thank you for giving me life thank you
for the shelter
thank you for the support now that's a
different way of
addressing the issue and then maybe
after a month or two of that
if you go into you know mom
i do know something about you yeah and
you flip
the judgment then [ __ ] gets really
interesting
yeah i i need to do that more i tend to
be very
defensive on everything that they say
about me foreign
you just beat me to it you know how many
people are watching right now who have
parents that don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i know
so be thankful every time they come at
you with like what are you doing 30
years old
your your cousin maria's [ __ ] married
you know all that [ __ ]
you just say thank you for caring about
me so much but i got this
thank you i appreciate you caring it
means the world to me that i have
parents that care
and then after you build a little bit of
that you go
by the way and that is where it gets
interesting
which is like i appreciate your judgment
of me now let me give you a little bit
about you
and i've you know it's not to try to
change them or anything
it's it's more of like trying them
trying to have them understand
where like where i'm coming from and how
thankful i
am for everything that they're doing for
me but also understand me
which to this day they haven't quite
figured me out yet
so it's it's maybe also because of the
way you communicate yourself to them
yeah yeah
yeah i'm super defensive
like super defensive yeah
never works yeah all right good luck
okay thank you so much you're welcome so
much good job
good show dust
very good long ones important ones
i like it uh
something i want to talk about you're
going to end with vayner gaming that was
a big announcement
small announcement tomorrow seth is
going to be doing this
instead of oh flat action tomorrow
seth's walking into a buzz transition
when you're transitioning to somebody
else people get real testy
um well okay cool you're gonna be
hanging with him or he's ready
yeah i'll be like i'll still be here
it's just a
rotating type of thing no no we need to
build that up
yeah all right love everybody hope
everybody has a great day two one two
nine three one five seven three one
if you want to get your question on
on the show here
hit me up with a question that's
somebody asked josh allen or darnold
it's not even close
carl's gonna be ten times better proud
than josh allen
all you buffalo fans are confused as
[ __ ] confused as [ __ ] by the soft
schedule last year
you weren't paying attention to how he
plays out
um awesome love you see you bye